hat man da ist der dschungel ist dass
der dschungel dschungel insel jungle
zekorn isley haben auf dem server gesund
sowie games dieses loya und stadt jemand
wieder von opiaten ehrliches leben
sowieso ich war fertig den kanal namen
aber auf jeden fall ich wenn ich jetzt
finde auch mal dann verlinkt ist ihr ein
video beschreibung richtig cooler kanal
der macht von uns also von conny und
jetzt auch gefragt ob der
videoausschnitt von uns leben darf und
so die beste aus eurem auch ja das haben
wir auch schon voll oft leute gefragt
und zwar werden immer immer mehr best of
von meinen videos gemacht
von mir wird immer verlangt hat sich das
selber machen soll was macht die
community für uns freiwillig das ist
richtig geil
ja ich bin auch also generell halte man
denkt so ich würde das gerne machen aber
ich denke ich will nicht gestreikt werde
so also habe die erlaubnis das zu machen
ihr seid natürlich unsere komplette
videos runterladen das komplette video
11 hochladen das wäre sinnlos aber falls
irgendwelche best aufstellen dass die
stellen oder sonst was ja habt oder
vater dann gut findet dann können und
uns dann als video und prozent oder so
also wenn es wieder so gut ist
vielleicht nimmt auch teil davon für ein
eigenes best of zu nehmen
besonders prominenten special sucht also
dann seid ihr verewigt
mit eurem werde das nicht mehr tun bin
ich denn verriet um
ich bin kurz davor war immer also ich
muss jetzt ein blaues portal setzen ein
blaues portal gut dann gleich wenn es
nach wird komme ich einfach mal nach
hause kommen können
dann setze ich in blogs portal kommen
ich suche verdammt nochmal rhabarber ist
ja aber du hast nicht hinein
ich suche rhabarber sap links war nicht
so so haben wir doch im sumpf hinter
welcher oder nein die setzlinge haben
bin ich kein sicherer betrieb noch im
sumpfloch welche ich meine jetzt nicht
dass ich auch hingehen will sah ich will
unseren kisten die finden aber keine
samplings von matschies ich glaube nicht
fürchte ich habe unsere würde gerade
gefunden das ist so ein schöner zombie
vor dem anschließen angst aber ich
glaube hier links müsste und sowie
design für mich nicht alles täuscht
ich weiß nicht ob ich fühle mich hier
mehr zu hause als bei uns im haus recht
ich weiß nicht
und dafür einstellen mal nichts konzept
von mir unter unten sondern skelett
jetzt will ich sterbe ich bin viel zu
jung
dann muss sitzen auf hockern einsetzen
mich bringt jetzt und jetzt runter und
sulawesi
wo habe ich ein like sie schon her dass
jobs abgebaut
wo waren hier noch mal ein lager bin
jetzt total verfrüht über monster ich
kann nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr
draußen weitermachen kann ich machen
sagt wenn du im bett bist du mich direkt
bei dir ja ich bin im bett es kommt
darauf hin
stark im boden ein doch jetzt glück
gehabt
aber hier daher aus dem dschungel frisch
rausgekommen weg will nicht dass jetzt
bei mir auch so legt wenn ich so lange
geschwindigkeiten wir bei mir läuft
alles normal
gut bei mir auch bis jetzt nicht wer den
pc als server läuft ganz gut da ich
backe immer kurze zeit wirklich im boden
drin aber dann bei dem blog unter mir ab
und dann läuft er wieder da ist es
spielern sein fenster die nicht hoch
gelegten taten nicht aus ich bin
übrigens er hat mich letztes auch eine
person eingeschrieben wollte ein best of
the beast con crafter und ungespielt
machen
natürlich dürfte auf jeden fall machen
sind der delta wirklich ganz lieb
gefragt und das ist dann noch immer ganz
cool oder laub des fakt ist natürlich
eigentlich auch okay also erlauben jetzt
einfach mal an der stelle genau was man
ansprechen wollte die leute dieses kann
dadurch einfach nur dass sowas machen
nur um krieg zu erhoffen also wenn ihr
das macht war jetzt bock drauf habt ist
auf jeden fall coole sache wenn jetzt
nur macht weil dann der festen
überzeugung dass wir die videos dann
leiten und kommentieren damit ihr halt
auf dem video 1000x oder so kommt ist
nicht der richtige weg also ich denke
mal die meisten videos oder die videos
wenn die so sind während wir
kommentieren wenn wir sehen und liken
gute rest of sind in arbeit zusammen
aber nicht dass sie dann ankommen zu ich
habe jetzt was oft gemacht hat für rein
steckt ist wieder auch licon und so viel
also
die box ab macht jetzt nicht er nicht
das macht jetzt nicht weil your lover
lover lover lover lover noch nicht okay
trust ist man zwar direkt neben mir ich
habe gleich gesehen hat und nein aller
mir gesagt hey das sind diamanten schaut
euch das an das ist nicolai auch wenn
auch anders geschrieben dass der wand
übersehen doch dann habe ich nicht
die sonst könne die runde wo ist leise
ich suche eisen ich habe hier ein nein
da sind 40 eisenbach i was geht mit dir
ab das heißt dass hierdurch ein bar
eingepackt
ja du geworden weil das geht aber
relativ schnell mit tommy ja okay nicht
relativ also im vergleich doch in
relativität zu der einzel spitzhacke
elze der man spitze gesehen geht es doch
relativ schnell und muss schon sagen ich
habe jetzt schon 2 wie viele brauchen
wir für ein sauberes tischreihe aber du
kannst du noch mehr mitbringen weil es
gibt so richtig geiles rezept das sind
so schule moment fall da meine long for
booty winwood blut es gibt irgendwie so
fall schuhe oder sowas
aber stil des nano street blues es gibt
auch welche besonders schuhe tommy and
bruce labruce oft ist scheffel blablabla
damit startet news keine ahnung rolle
das hört sich so an wie sonja lang
vollmuth allofs sieht ja an zwei
diamanten und sechs eisen machen dann
machen wir nur einen schub wasser zwei
schuhe dafür dass heißt brauchst
insgesamt 2 obsidian für ein paar schuhe
vier diamanten sind da kann ich einfach
mit dem film vertrauens tisch und und
weißt was du machen kannst du kannst du
überall runterspringen und du stirbst
ich völlig falsch ein
krass das brauche ich kenne also schön
viele diamanten sammeln fehlt obsidian
sondern als gut alles gut einleben
jetzt sag mal wie viel ich ungefähr
brauche werde letztlich die ganze zeit
hier unten bleiben und so zehn obsidian
hast schaffst das habe bisher acht ja
dann eine gute sache
geschirr wird ab ich mache eine schere
kam mit der schere weißt du was ich weiß
weiß aber immer die schere nimmt und
damit blätter abschneidet kommt auch sap
heraus
ne-yo blätter bist du dir sicher ich
glaube schon jetzt mal hier mal da ist
fix dabei 3 sap links mal auf settings
frost aber es kommt wieder
hey baby
ich versuche einfach mal diese blätter
hier von unseren körper abzubauen habe
ich jetzt helfe ich nehme einfach 12 mit
gibt es überhaupt in level 2
das setzt sich jetzt mal waypoint und
obsidian ist der spieltag in normalen
jahren
doch hier geht als instant die farbe
soll dunkel die da sein
hier fallen keine doch schießt er bringt
sehr gutes paket so ok hier ist obsidian
da mache ich hier noch eben ein portal
ich meine haltung zu labbadia zu fahren
ist abbauen
der riesige roboter reform so freunde
diese folge ein bisschen länger und zwar
machen wir in 12 minuten aufnahmestopp
weil ich dann wird essen muss das dann
könnt ihr wieder vielleicht kommt darin
schreiben uns an die nächste folge dann
feuer direkt an die man zwar sich auf
jeden fall schreiben könnt sind zum
beispiel sachen die wir machen könnten
also vorschläge nicht nur sachen hilfe
so als sie ja um das zu machen brauchte
das dass du sagst soll die anlage bauen
können hinauf sachen zum beispiel eine
gute idee mal in der expression in news
zu unternehmen oder wäre es eine gute
idee das sind das zu machen oder so also
dass wir auch mal einfach eure um
vorschläge die wir machen sollen oder
können in die tat umsetzen können finde
ich ganz spannend okay gut ich bin zu
hause mit 14 obsidian und ein paar
anderen erst jetzt erstmal die ganzen
kisten hier
und so ich würde sagen wenn wir müssen
die kiste nicht mal so nach rang
sortieren welchem etwas cooles
beinhalten welche nicht ja es macht auf
jeden fall und dann würde ich sagen ich
natürlich ganz schnell wieder mit dem
hahn abholen noch bevor will konstantin
bauer auf entfernen hier die unsere
meppen tredup dieses dicke ding ab sei
es sehr gut du hast das regal
ich geb dir das spielen wenn du mehr
draußen rumlaufen kriegst du das erste
tor zurück also wenn du sowas gelbe sie
sind einfach mit rechtsklick traf
freunde dann würde ich sagen sehen uns
in der nächsten folge immer wenn's euch
gefallen hat dürfte eine positive
bewertung da lassen wir haben jetzt in
dieser aufnahme session das geschafft
war nur vier folgen die wir diesmal
aufgenommen vergabe viel schafft die
sensation mit dem die rettungsstation
mit dem mit der formel war der
überhebliche und nächste folge werden
wir denke ich erst mal verzauberung
tisch bauen damit ich endlich meine 40
level auf schwerter verwenden kann und
so weiter und ich packe irgendwie 'ne
kiste
ich weiß nicht 11